[Music]
it reminds our generations moral
imperative to take responsibility for
what our children learn we must turn our
focus right now to the message and
content they exposed to on a daily basis
through social media the bullying the
experience online and in person that was
a First Lady Melania Trump speaking at
the UN yesterday about cyber bullying so
how did the left
how do liberals react well they attacked
the first lady online one person tweeted
oh just watch Melania Trump speech for
some reason it made me think of the
blueberry girl from Willy Wonka whatever
that means and during an interview
Hillary Clinton even took a shot at the
first lady for not doing enough really
joining us now foxnews contributors
tommy Lehren and Jessica tarlowe you
know if this ever had one when we
criticized Michelle Obama conservatives
when she injected herself into politics
and said for the first time in my adult
life I'm proud of my country the left
went nuts they made fun of Melania shoes
what she wears - hurricane Harvey
aftermath where's your side defending
women here right here Hillary Clinton
didn't know well the point that Hillary
Clinton made was a policy point and I
think that's completely sound don't pick
on her outfit it also was fabulous but
Melania Trump picking up cyberbullying
as Hort as her patron saint cause after
what Donald Trump tweeted even just last
weekend right the golf swing and the
golf ball hitting Hillary and the ballot
humorless are you really you know what I
don't think Tommy gets hit harder than
me yeah Tommy you just don't do what the
left does weak conservatives wouldn't do
it and if they did do it
they beat we're gonna kill them raked
over the coals well here's my question
for Jessica I mean isn't this supposed
to be a platform the left loves we're
talking about bullying we're talking
about cyberbullying we're talking about
being
pick it for that Melania Trump is coming
out and something that's not partisan at
all this is just a human thing but yet
they attack her for what she's wearing
and it's again where are the feminists
they never come out they never come out
with Sanders everywhere they're just not
supporting Kellyanne Conway who
advocates for policies that hurt women
they're not thrilled at hope it's why
she does not talking about Kellyanne
Melania you think that if you have the
tape for an agenda that does not help
win and get better access to health care
that does not raise the minimum wage
that does not support maternity leave
one other time Tommy we're talking about
cyberbullying we're talking about
Melania Trump advocating for an end to
cyber bullying but yet the left goes
after her and they ridicule her Allah I
don't see the feminists coming out
saying hey leave leave a woman alone
leave an empowered female alone I don't
see the feminists doing that just I
don't know I totally take your point I
think that Melania should not be
ridiculed for taking about that cause
certainly not ready cooled for her
outfit I was outraged when people after
went after Michelle Obama because she
wore some j.crew you know and Melania
for these were some j.crew but the issue
with her taking up cyberbullying when
her husband is the biggest cyber bully
of them all is the problem why isn't she
advocating for this at home could I just
say one that you attack Kellyanne come
on Kellyanne come I like Kelly I've
known for you to say she doesn't
advocate for women she's the first woman
to ever win a national campaign as a
campaign manager and all she came
because she's poor Eliza I went because
she's Tim Kaine is pro-life Joe Biden
okay point is
she doesn't this why are you attacking
her and she women that are strong and
independent
oh listen as I said I like Kelly Ann
Conway a lot I have great respect for
what she achieved there should have been
more articles about what she
accomplished the issue is with the
agenda that she and the transition Tommy
what's an T woman about Trump's agenda
well I think what's interesting as well
as we've got President Trump who's
empowered many women look at his press
secretary look at his White House
communications director look at his
campaign manager all women he has
empowered women but no the left they
like to forget that because all he sent
off some mean tweets that's all they can
think about he does
actually think about the steps and the
actions of President Trump what he's
done to actually it advanced anaphor
you're winning
Tommy you really are you so sensitive
you people don't let them generate your
sticks and stones thing here you know
what liberals are vicious to
conservatives constantly I think both
sides are vicious
so then call out your site I call you
out and I implore liberals to attack on
the basis of poor policies and not poor
fashion even though I did like that
outfit thank you both